coca-cola
a 130-year-old iconic brand and a
dominant force in the 800 billion dollar
soft drink industry synonymous with
globalization
coca-cola operates in over 200 countries
worldwide
the beverage behemoth now has a new ceo
james quincy spent the last two decades
rising through the ranks at coca-cola
now as head of the company quincy aims
to win over a new generation
that shuns sugar and to show the world
that he
takes the environment seriously even
as he adapts to a new world of
technology
james quincy sat down with us for an
extended conversation
we wanted to understand how he plans to
use innovation
to transform every aspect of coca-cola
attempting to change its culture while
managing a global checkerboard of
regulations
and tax regimes
coca-cola operates in a lot of different
countries which means there's a lot of
different regulatory systems a lot of
different legal schemes you have to
really
adapt to let's talk about a couple of
those first of all the united states
uh the tax cuts how does it affect
coca-cola yeah we're still working
through the numbers i mean our tax rate
last year effectively was about 24
so it's not the biggest change to us
because we're an international company
the absolute rate hasn't affected us as
much as perhaps some of the more
domestically
focused enterprises but but we're
positive on the moving the territorial
system so
uh we think the simplification is
positive in the long run
uh to the extent that it helped create
more demand that will be good news
too we're still working through the
numbers that we'll we'll lay out on our
on our earnings call of course we're
part of uh having some of the money
uh overseas but in the end if it
generates more economic growth that will
lift all the votes
does the expensing of capital investment
affect you at all not in a great amount
i mean it will make some difference
we'll we'll lay that out but that's not
the biggest moving piece for us
and if there is significant incremental
cash available to coca-cola
have you decided yet does it go into
capital investment does it go into
buybacks of shares does it go into uh
dividends
uh i mean we weren't short of cash uh at
the end of the day so
you know we've been a successful company
we we've got the resources we need to
invest in the marketplace we're still
working through exactly
how the the puts and takes work because
obviously got to pay tax on the cash
first
or in addition um so we're looking at
how
how we use all that and how we make the
right capital allocations
one of the really big issues for the
united states right now is the so-called
dreamers
these are the young people were brought
here as children and the question is do
they get to stay as adults
essentially do you have a coca-cola
people who are uh really
uncertain about whether they can stay or
not they're about 700 000 more or less
nationwide
yeah we have some people in in our in
our company and and in our bottling
partners who fall under the dreamers or
the dakar program
um you know we we would love uh
government to find a way to make
proper underlying immigration uh reform
and including finding a solution uh for
that for the dreamers so that it's that
it's not so
disruptive and then they can stay so
hopefully they'll find a path to that
um of course uh partial solutions may be
necessary but we would love to see
fundamental reform
you ran mexico for coca-cola at one
point so you have seen this issue on
both sides of at least our southern
border
do you see a path forward a constructive
path forward on immigration
i think there's a path forward but i
think it also is connected and it can't
be completely dis
disassociated when you think about
long-term fundamental reform
from getting both economies to grow in
the end
part of what drives the the the informal
in immigration
is the disparity in in the economic
outlook so
having a community of north america
where all the economies are growing
um actually help solve that problem too
so i think
you know leadership from the united
states to drive growth
will help solve some of these other
issues too you've also seen nafta
from both sides of the border you've
seen that issue which is another hot
issue right now in the united states has
nafta overall been good or bad for the
united states
my view would be that free trade deals
are good overall for
all participants and i think it's been
good for north america and
all the countries all the countries in
it doesn't mean it's perfect
very few free trade deals are perfect so
can it be made better
yes i hope they can make it better but i
don't think we should
start uh uh deconstructing global trade
i think it's been a powerful engine uh
for lifting all boats
it doesn't mean it solved all problems
there are questions of income inequality
there are questions of not all the rules
were were perfect and need to be
improved
but let's go forward not backwards so
when president trump trump first came in
he was very closely allied with
many people in business he consulted he
had panels that he talked with as well
do you get to talk either president
trump or the administration about things
like nafta i mean do they consult you or
do you
make your views known to them when there
are things where we have a
view or it affects our business we make
our views known
either directly to the administration or
through many of the the business forums
like the business roundtable uh there
are there are enough points of
intersection
um collectively and individually with
the administration that
everyone they know what uh they know
what we think so from that do you have
any sense of where we're headed with
nafta because there's the conflicting
reports i mean the canadians
seem to be preparing for actually u.s
withdrawal there are a lot of people in
washington say no we're not going to
withdraw do you have any sense from your
point of view
of where we're headed um my view on
negotiations is you've got to let the
negotiations negotiate and if you're not
in the room
you don't know what the answer is until
it comes out so i think the the
important thing for those that aren't in
the room is
to keep saying what they what they
believe to be true what they believe to
be
the areas where things can be made
better and then the negotiators have got
to get in the room and thrash it out and
trying to work out
what color the smoke is coming from the
room uh doesn't lead you anywhere in
until they come out and tell you what
the answer is your native country has
voted in
referendum uh to leave the eu and i want
to ask you what you think about that
but tell us how that's developing i mean
is there a soft landing there that you
can see
how would we get to it um
it does a bit go back to my point about
negotiations you're never really sure
until the you know until the cake is
cooked
i myself i think the logic uh
of the economics is a softer rather than
a harder brexit
um you know i i think in the end whilst
it won't be a catastrophe
one way or the other life will be better
you know there'll be more uh economic
growth if it's a softer brexit
but there's a lot of details and a lot
of different points of view to work out
because in the end
uh the the referendum wasn't between do
you want
this or that it's like do you want this
or not want this it wasn't a referendum
around the version
of the exit which is kind of where we're
trapped at the moment
and of course there's a lot of
negotiations going on it's very
important to get it right
for the uk and and to some extent for
europe as well
whether it's brexit or whether it's
nafta how do these trade issues
affect coca-cola's business i think one
of the
one of the great benefits of the
coca-cola system is we
we're global but we're extremely local i
mean we manufacture
in every country virtually that we sell
in
um virtually everything that's sold in
the us is made in the u.s virtually
everything that's sold in mexico is made
in mexico very virtually everything that
sold in the uk or france is made in that
individual country so
the global trade restrictions or
openings don't tend to affect us
heavily in the moment to the extent that
they reduce
or increase total economic growth that's
what matters to us
and so i think philosophically we're pro
global free trade because it drives
economic growth therefore
let's focus on making those deals better
because it will provide the wealth to
then solve a lot of society's
society's problems you came in and took
over coca-cola
and really trumpeted innovation as
critical to your future
i believe you have a chief innovation
officer but maybe you're the chief
innovation officer in some sense
how do you innovate in a 130 year old
company that's so well known around the
world has been there for so long
has such an entrenched perception of
people's views
it's hard i mean any institution that's
been around a long time whether it's a
company or
a government organizer or any
organization it's going to be very hard
so i think
from my point of view it's i'm if i'm
not the chief innovator i'm certainly
the chief agitator for innovation
um and and what that means is you know
driving the culture
to try and do a few things upon top of
everything else we do
stay curious if we're not curious about
the outside world about the consumers
about the customer about what's changing
how will we innovate but curiosity just
leads you to an insight it's very
passive
you need to drive empowerment so people
feel they can go and do something that
they're not waiting for head office to
make the decision that they can get up
in the morning
and go and do something and i think the
next thing is
you've got to be inclusive you've got to
try and connect the pieces because we've
got a tremendous
global knowledge and tremendous global
system sometimes your idea has already
been tried somewhere else so
connect to the other parts of the system
and lastly
you know we probably fell into the trap
we're trying to make things perfect
before we did anything in the past no we
need to learn from some of the software
companies
have version 1.0 2.0 3.0
that gets us both innovation and speed
and if we keep pushing those four things
i think will will make progress and how
do you know
how does james quincy know whether
you're getting the innovation job done
and i mean that in the sense you're
sitting atop a very large organization
a lot of people spread around the world
how do you judge whether the word's
getting down and
people are already changing their
behavior it's it's hard to know but you
have the only way
forward is to look for multiple uh
signals no there's no one number or one
metric that's going to give it yet so we
have
employee surveys where we where we ask
people we can look at the sales number
and
measure uh the success rate or the
number and the success rate of the
things we put into the marketplace
we can look at what our research and
development pipeline is generating and
are we really
getting new patents are we really making
progress i think one has to have a
dashboard
to look across and say is there is there
progress technology it's disrupting just
about every company
that we know of today how is it
affecting coca-cola and first talk about
how it's affecting your relationship
with your consumer
how you deliver to your consumer things
like e-commerce
how you market to your consumer yeah i
mean we kind of look at it in three
buckets how we engage with consumers
uh uh you know either used to be tv
advertising now the social media the
the ways of engaging with the consumer
are changing rapidly
who the customer is and how the shopping
actually happens is changing rapidly and
of course internally is changing rapidly
with the consumer around the world you
know tv is still the biggest vehicle
maybe less so in some of the developed
economies but around the world is still
the biggest vehicle but a lot of it's
going to social media we
we work closely a lot with a lot of the
new tech
companies in social media trying to find
ways
to you know continue to have a brand
role i mean in the end
someone's got to pay for the for the the
content to be developed whether that's
through advertising or sponsorship so
uh i think there's a lot of change going
on we're adapting i think
we feel we're kind of towards the front
end
but i'm what i'm totally clear of it's
going to be different in five years and
it's going to be very different in 10
years and we're going to have to keep
investing in innovation and keep
evolving to stay close to the consumers
as you look around the world which
markets do you see the fastest
innovation when it comes to e-commerce
when we just
sort of get on your app and you order
something up it gets delivered for
example
is it china is it the united states is
it europe
uh i actually think that places like
shanghai and some parts of western
europe
are on the cutting edge along with uh
some of the bits of the us but
really it apart i mean you know the u.s
in many respects there's a there's a lot
of advanced
e-commerce but i can tell you it's very
advanced uh in places like shanghai and
and western europe as well and the
penetration e-commerce
uh in aggregate is even higher in some
of those places than even the us so
you know when you want to learn what's
going on i would be just as tempted to
tell you go to shanghai
as go to stay in new york and how do you
market
in that circumstance i mean we're used
to going to a fast food restaurant for
example there's a
coca-cola there it's on the menu so
let's have that coke or that diet coke
you don't have that when you're on your
app no but you have to get it
i mean you know if you went back even
two or three years in china for example
uh when a lot of the apps and the and
the and the the mobile payment systems
came in
uh we weren't on the menu actually even
worse we were trying to sell perhaps a
returnable glass bottle to the
restaurant
which had no way of being in the
delivery system so we've had to
re-engineer our business system very
quickly to both
be present on the app so what's the
virtual representation of what you'd
normally see in the store
and how do we change the packaging
portfolio so that we can be part of the
delivery system and you have a lot of
places in shanghai
where all food ordered on apps and
delivered is thirty fifty percent of
the of the restaurant sales that's
relationship with the consumer
talk about coca-cola as coca-cola how is
technology changing the way you do
business and for that matter your
workforce
it's changing it in lots of profound
ways i mean in in simple terms
you know you go back 10 20 years we were
a large company and we're one of the few
that could afford to invest
in expensive it systems and do our own
stuff our own programs our own server
farms
you wind forward to today that's no
longer the model we've had to move to
the cloud
we've had to move to standard uh
programs that whole industries use and
we had to use the mobile
um the one thing i always say to the it
department is
just put it on the phone everything can
be done on the phone let's just move
everything to mobile on the phone the
the old days of it had training budgets
why everyone knows how to use the apps
on the phone so it's profoundly changing
the way the way that we work and i think
it's going to continue
to flow through the organization we have
a big program of digitizing the company
does that translate into fewer employees
as a practical matter because of the
efficiencies from digital
i think it for sure it changes into a
different profile i mean people are
having to adapt to doing things
uh in a different way yeah we're gonna
we've actually made a lot of changes in
i.t departments to move to a different
skill set so it's certainly changing
the nature of employment and the sorts
of profiles you want
whether we buy the services ourselves or
we
buy the services or do it ourselves
makes a difference as to where the
employees are
but net net more employment is being
generated in the economies
so can coca-cola compete with silicon
valley and the digital startups when
you're trying to recruit the young
computer scientists
well atlanta is a very fast-growing
economy
the state of georgia has been ranked you
know top one or two of
place to do business in the us for many
years in a row the local
political system has done a great job uh
so is the city so uh it's a very
competitive economy there
and and we do very well in it we're
happy to see atlanta and georgia growing
um and they've done a lot to invest in
tech startups and and
and the media industry uh in and near
atlanta and it's being very successful
as you look toward really substantial
growth in these new beverage categories
are you looking at acquisitions are you
looking at organic growth i mean you
have been inclined i believe
to look for smaller brands startup
brands bringing them along is that the
future path
to a significant degree for coca-cola um
i think it's gonna be both i mean we we
we have grown organically but we have
made these bolt-on acquisitions as we
call them the little small ones the
niche brands
i think where we see that something is a
really good idea
we invest in them sometimes we buy them
sometimes we just invest with them
um but there's a there's a quid pro quo
uh they
they get the capital that we inject yet
we can introduce them to the globe not
just the country that they've launched
in
and that's helped us double the number
of billion dollar brands that we sell
around the world so i think it's going
to be an and uh strategy rather than one
or the other
it's interesting it's a total beverage
company it's not a food company i mean
there are some competitors who said
let's become a food company at least in
part
why did you make that decision and does
it make you any more vulnerable
for giving me for saying but even to
acquisition i mean you're what 200
billion dollar market cap it's a pretty
big acquisition
but there are some pretty big
consolidations in the food industry out
there
um i think firstly you know we're
focused on beverages because that's
where the greatest synergy
and the greatest application of our
know-how and
our fabulous global bottling
distribution system is it's the thing
that can
be most synergistic with what we've
already got and the market
for beverages is one of the best growing
markets in the whole of the supermarket
or
or in the other store so it's a it's a
great market we have a good position we
can create a lot of synergy so it's a
it's a question of choices um i i
sometimes say
i never say never which then causes
confusion because people say you haven't
ruled anything out say no it's a
question of what's most logical
and beverages are the most not logical
thing for us to do
first because we stick to our knitting
in terms of how
how we think about the consolidation in
the end of the day i'm pretty convinced
that
investors gold star goes to those that
grow
with expanding margins growth is the
name of the game
if the category's got no growth then
optimize the margin
okay but that's still silver prize
largely over the long term
so i'm pretty clear if we focus uh on
driving top-line growth
which we believe we can with our
strategy of total beverages and we will
attract an investor base that will be
very happy
with us over the long run world without
waste great goal
you have a big new packaging
announcement why is it important to
coca-cola not just as a corporate
citizen
but as a business you know it's
important to us for the
for a very core part of our values we've
always believed
that to have a healthy business you need
to be operating in a healthy community
and one of today's biggest problems is
packaging waste we've we've done a lot
on
making things recyclable we've actually
invested a lot of r d
making progress on reusing it what we
need to do is collect it so this
announcement is about
the big missing piece in generating a
world without waste which is
collecting back the plastic and creating
a market economy for that collective
plastic
and i think that's going to do great
things to help us grow
into the future without creating waste
which is good for us
and it's great for communities how are
you going to attract all that plastic by
2030 you want to be getting a bottle
back for everyone you put out there
that's a lot of bottles for coca-cola
how are you going to attract all that
plastic well to give you an idea of the
dimension
we need to bring back every person in
the world if they bring back two bottles
a month
we bring back all our bottles that's our
objective two bottles a month for every
person we collect every bottle we
we put out how we're going to do it well
there'll be different systems in
different countries you know
every country needs a solution but it
won't be the same everywhere
there are kind of places where it's
reasonably advanced in europe
to more informal economies where the
collection happens
so there's going to be different
solutions everywhere we have to work
with
ngos other industrial companies and
governments to put in place these
solutions but it's absolutely doable
and i think that's what's exciting about
setting the objective we're very
conscious in the united states but what
about in other places like
china for example yeah look i think the
emerging and the developed countries are
where more of the problem is than
the us or you know europe which is
probably at the leading edge so we need
to do more there
but recognize in a lot of these
countries there is some informal
collection system already going on
across a wide range of uh waste what we
need to create is the circular economy
we need to create
value for that so often in the case and
we did this in mexico for example
you go back a little more than 10 years
it was less than 10
of the plastic was recycled now it's 60
percent
how the informal economy was collecting
the waste but there was no market for it
no one wanted to buy it
so we went into the marketplace and
bought the plastic invested in
factories to recycle that and reuse it
in all that in our bottles so i think
there's a model there for the china's
and other parts of the world
on how to create value out of plastic
and get it reused
you've laid out a bold strategic vision
for your company
called total beverage company that
includes things beyond coca-cola and
even
beyond diet coke it goes on beyond that
to these five categories
what's driving that is that basically to
get away a bit from sugar
drinks uh actually you know we're
following the consumer
when you look at what's happening around
the world as as the world is urbanizing
as people have got more disposable
income
they're spending more money on a range
of things including beverages
so what's important within that growing
market of beverages is they want more
choice
different people want different things
so if we really want to be able to serve
the customer
serve the consumer we've got to follow
them we've got to get into more
categories
coke is likely to remain the heart and
soul of the company it's
the world's biggest fast-moving consumer
good brand
but we need more we need to offer
consumers what they want all day long
we have to offer choice and i think
that's what's going to guide us forward
and in a way it goes back to where we
started if we pay
a lot of attention to what the consumer
wants they will take us to where the
business needs to grow
and then it ultimately ends up in growth
for the business
i understand that on average around the
world people consume about eight ounces
of a beverage per day
and coca-cola i was told is about a half
an ounce uh
what is your goal how much of the market
share of total beverage
can you really take globally i mean i i
don't think there's a
end of history moment when we reach uh
reach nirvana i think what we're looking
to do
is gain share every year i mean it's a
competitive marketplace we have a lot of
well-funded uh competitors doing a lot
of exciting things
so what we're focused on is can we serve
the consumers and gain a little bit of
share each year
and generate a growing business system
that our objective is create value for
everyone who touches that business
system whether it be
the economics of the people who are in
the value chain like the customer
or even society with with initiatives
like the packaging one
you know which i think builds on our
heritage of creating such shared value
in the world
um you know 10 years ago or so we set
ourselves the objective of being water
neutral
by 2020 and we achieved it a few years
early so we return to the environment
all the water we use which is one of the
things that gives us confidence that we
can achieve this packing
packaging objective so we get business
growth and
doing it in the right way for society
okay thanks very much that's we're
wrapping up there this is terrific thank
you so much that was really fun
thank you